الى القاهره مراسله صباح العربيه نجاح
حجازي نادي يسعد صباحك اهلا بك يا ندى كيف
احتفل يا هلا بهالطله يا ندى كيف احتفلت
القاهره براس السنه الجديده
ههه صباح الخير يا نادين صباح الخير يا
سهام اا احنا عندنا يوم راس السنه ده مهم
جدا جدا بالنسبه للمصريين اجتماعيه ونفسيه
وحتى على صعيد الشغل وكل حاجه ده يوم مميز
جدا والناس دائما بتعتبروا بدايه جديده
لكل حاجه في حياتهم وده حتى بيبقى ظاهر
جدا على السوشيال ميديا ودائما الناس
تلاقيه بتكتب بقى الاهداف بتاعتها
والحاجات اللي هم ناويين يسيبوها تمشي مع
السنه القديمه ومهما كانت السنه صعبه اللي
انتهت دائما المصريين بيبقى عندهم امل
وطموحات وبيعملوا اللست كده لاهدافهم
علشان يبداوا بخطب جديده طبعا احنا عندنا
الاحتفالات بتبقى في كل مكان اي شارع
هتدخليها هتسمعي موسيقى هتسمعي ناس بتغني
يعني
اسمحي لي بس خليني هيك انا استفسر منك
كل الوقت الشارع مليان اختي زحمه اسامه
امير سيارات فانا كيف بدي اتخيل انه ليله
نيويورك كيف بدها تكون الجو شو راح يختلف
اكثر راح يكون مضاعف في العشقه ولا كيف
والله هو بقى يعني يوم راس السنه بيبقى
برده زحمه بس زحمه مبهجه عارفه كده يعني
زحمه تحسي الناس متقبله زحمه اكثر ايوه
ثاني دائما الناس بتكون الصبح كده في
الزحمه بتبقى حاسه ان هي متعطله
بس في يوم راس السنه احنا بنحب نروح حتى
الاماكن الزحمه وبنحب يعني نشارك فرحتنا
نعلن واللي ما نعرفهمش
وفي كثير بس في ناس كثير بتقعد في البيت
برده
مش الاغلبيه لكن في ناس بتعزم عائلتها
كمان في البيت وبيعملوا عزومه كبيره واللب
والسوداني
العائليه الجميله دي وت على سلك
ومن تقاليدنا وتقسنا في راس السنه ان احنا
نتخلص من كل حاجاتنا القديمه اللي احنا
نحب نحب نجيب جديد بدالها يعني تلاقي
الناس دائما بتتخلص من هدومها القديمه
اللي مش حابينها اا اي حاجه عندهم حابين
يجيبوا لها جديد بيتخلصوا منها
شعرك جديد وبرده البنات دائما يروحوا
يصبغوا شعرهم ويكتبوا يعملوا النيولوكس
جديده برده عشان احنا دائما بنات كده بنحس
انه انا لما باغير لون شعري او باغير شكله
شخصيه جديده هبقى عندي يعني حياه جديده
كلها سعاده عليك يا ندى شكرا جزيلا لك من
القاهره